technology plays a really important role
in design in the 21st century Architects
and other designers are able to more
quickly create their designs they're
actually able to spend more time
designing and understanding the
implications of their design through
analysis and visualization and
simulation and less time drawing Lego
uses digital design software to create
the shape initially in the computer and
then they are able to take that digital
design and go through a number of
software packages to come up with
construction drawings that they hand off
to their builders to create something
like the 62,000 brick Lego dinosaur
this is a hollow body surf board made by
42 surfboards up in Oregon they are
using trees that are blown down in wind
storms that they then take and put into
a milling machine that is controlled by
the computer software
this is the one laptop per child project
this design team was faced with a lot of
real-world challenges that they had to
meet so some of those challenges
included these laptops being used in
developing countries where there may not
be accessed to a power grid so they came
up with the hand crank to power up the
laptop and solar panels that can power
the laptop also they understood that
there was these were going to be used by
kids and so it's a very rugged design it
has a cover over the keyboard so if you
spill your juice on it it's still going
to function they had to work within a
very very tight price point the goal was
a hundred-dollar laptop and so the
design team leveraged single elements to
serve dual purposes so for example the
latches that help you close the lid of
the laptop also serve as the antenna for
the laptop everything from laptops to
large dinosaurs that go into theme parks
two buildings often use many many
different software programs to go from
initial concept all the way through
finished product
you